the Germans grabbed my arm I had to make
a fist they slammed in arm onto a table
and with a hypodermic needle every
little dot was injected until it became
in my case the number be seven six four
eight in the middle of the night they
kicked down the door they were yelling
and screaming my mom and dad were at a
loss they grabbed me to protect me
especially from the German shepherds
which were pretty much at my level they
took us out on the truck I of course was
scared I was confused I had no way of
doing anything to escape
we were taken off and we were greeted by
people who had an emaciated Howell look
they really moved like zombies
my father was forced to work repairing
the electrified fences my mother made
iron plates that went under the military
boots hide miraculously was given the
chance to work in the Agriculture
Department the food ration that you
received was a single loaf of bread a
watery cabbage soup intentionally non
nutritional that was your total food for
the week as far as I was concerned I had
an escape mechanism from that level of
salvation by stealing food as much as I
could the way I stole it was by putting
holes in my pocket let the seeds fall
down to my ankles where the pant leg had
been tightened up I was able to pass
inspection by being patted down and I've
been detected I would have become what
the Germans called Sunday's
entertainment the execution by hanging
one of the saddest moments in the ghetto
was that when my dad came home laid down
since there was no furniture and simply
expired the sidewalk would be littered
by the corpses of those that had passed
away the night before and they had a
wagon pulled by two or three people come
and collect the corpses that to me was
more painful than seeing my dad give up
his life or pass away what will be done
to him after he passed when I went to
work the next morning I did see him
laying naked we need to be picked up
but this wagon taking to a grave floor
already several people have been buried
and plop you fall down into heap of
bodies that was painful
[Music]
one Nazi dragged my well away and it is
that you belong over there the other
side I didn't call him mommy or anything
like this
there was no time to do this I realized
very quickly to see my mother again is
not ever ever going to happen they
shaved our hair they pushed that through
an archway and doused us with a painful
liquid we were washed for about ten
seconds and I'm pushed against the large
building with a huge smokestack in an
enormous flame and the most obnoxious
odor that we could not recognize we were
packed in with the density of standing
room only you could hardly move we hear
a noise and realized that looking up to
airplanes were circling the train they
had circulated signals
predominantly French fighter planes and
also accompanied by British fighter
planes they miss recognized and
designated as apparently returning
German military and that was my good
fortune to be at the very front of the
wagon and not be in the trajectory of
the machine got fired when they had made
two runs we lost about 30 to 40 percent
of the inhabitants of each wagon with
all the carnage the train went on those
of us who could survive on the piece of
bread and a bowl of soup simply hung in
suicides into the electrified wires
finding maybe an excuse to be shot
through aunt their life was not unusual
on Friday April 11 at 3:15 we hear a
very unfamiliar noise and mechanical
noise I see a tank coming up being
familiar with German insignia I didn't
see that what I saw instead of a lot of
things was a white star of david' the
commander were uniform of the United
States Third Army headed by General
George Patton
[Music]
it's difficult to reach of 88 and see
the world not getting along with one
another I witness cause of our Somalia
the for Rwanda and another 20 different
genocides since world war two and one
Sunday morning saying mr. trump asked
but the audience is supposed to support
to raise their hand and give an oath
things like this are not very welcome to
somebody who survived the Holocaust
democracy I believe has a chance to be
greatly diminished in our country are we
actually going to build a fence around
our country and make a ghetto out of the
United States are we going to have 11
million people sent out and make
refugees I just simply cannot accept
that America goes the way of Germany at
one time have we learned anything about
world war two Korean War Vietnam the
Iraqi Wars people choose not to live in
peace based on certain agendas whether
political or in some cases religious so
we have to learn not just from a
Holocaust because it is historical fact
that people don't seem to be able to
live in peace and an agreement for a
better life
[Music]